こんなに頑張ってるっていうのは主張なの
か実際にどんな実績を出しているのか人は
その人のほっす心のイメージ写真を実現し
ていく。今言った精神的にも経済的にも
報いてないから見下り反下下されるわけ
じゃん。青木サの人生系哲学100回聞い
たら豊かになる話
。
今日の質問は一生懸命しっかりと仕事をしているのに全く
評価されず報酬も上がりません。こんな扱いを受けるなら全力で仕事をする必要なんかない。仕事を頑張る方が負けなんじゃないかと思ってしまうことがあります。どうすれば良いでしょうかというご説です。
なるほど。
[音楽]
深刻だね。ねえ、これは確かにね。
ただね、ポイントはね、まずね、事実か
解釈か、事実は1つ、解釈は無数と、ま、
解釈っていうのはその人の捉えている世界
なんだけど、もう1つ真実ってのもあるん
ですよ。私は今この質問いただいた方にね
、お聞きしたいのはリザルト、実績、
どんな実を作っているのかってことだと
思う。こんなに頑張ってるっていうのは
主張なのか事実
じゃあ給料の何倍の付加価値を生み出して
いるのか実際にどんな実績を出しているの
かこれだと思うのよ。早期なんかも優秀だ
よ。だって事実これ1年3ヶ月で
6万3000人超えてるわけじゃん。
YouTube。これはやっぱり早期の
能力を証明してるよね。実も私は早期に
引かれたことをただ答えてるだけだからさ
、言語も何もないわけだし。ま、本当に
そういう意味では実だと思うのよ。だ僕は
うちの会社は244人社員がいる
けれど実のある人間を軽く扱わないで私は
恩返しをします。恩返師とは何かと言うと
、まず精神的にも認める、承認する、大切
にする。このまずは心としてあり方として
全面的にその人に対して感謝を表す。これ
心のあり方だよね。でもこれだけで終わっ
ちゃダメなんだよ。これで終わって給料
変わらないっていうんではそれはさ、利用
してるようなもんじゃん。ありがとう。
本当に感謝してるよと同時に実績には商心
昇格さらにはま、うちの場合は決算商与ね
。年に1回の税引合利益の3割を社員に
分配をする。これが私の愛なんですよ。だ
から愛には2つあってね、精神的に目には
見えないけれども本当に相手に対して
思いやりやその慈しみや真心を持って
関わっていくというそういう関わり方と
もう1つは豊かにするってことなんだよ。
こう豊かにしてくれる人と一緒に働きたい
んだよ。だ、今のこの質問してくれた方は
まず1つはだから自分の実だよね。
パフォーマンスを見るってことです。で、
そのパフォーマンスも自分の自力で出て
いるのか、会社のトータルなブランドや
資源や会社の資本や様々な力を使って
生み出してるのか。大企業で結構自分は
こんだけ活躍しましたって言って転職し
たら転職した先では全然活躍しないって
やつがいるわけで、それはその前の会社の
やっぱりこのブランドだとかそこで使える
資源を使ってパフォーマンスを出したんで
場所が変わるとパフォーマンス下が
るっていうのはこれは本当の実力じゃない
んですよ。本当の実力というのは、ま、
例えを言うなら甲子園野球の監督は学校
変わってもまた優勝校校に育ててくじゃん
。あれは実力があるんですよ。監督が選手
育成のノウハウスキルを持って
るってことだよね。だから本来いい転職
ってどんどん映るたびにステージも実績も
上がり収入も増えてくって。これはまさに
人材流動化ならいい意味で、それはなぜ
なら移られる方に問題があるわけだから、
そういう優秀な人間をとめておく力がない
ことに問題があるんだ。これはやめてく
人間に問題があるんじゃないんだよ。だ、
今言った精神的にも経済的にも報いてない
から見下り反下されるわけじゃん。いや、
そういうことなんだよ。ケチな経営者って
雨なんだ、これ。ともかくどうしたら
報いるか。ま、僕は性格的にもオープンな
ので実力主義ともかく政党にフェアーにね
、公平に構成にちゃんとそういう評価して
あげたい。だから精神的な報酬と役職も
そうだし、小心昇格の仕組みもオープンに
なっているので、その自分の給料は誰が
決めてるか世の中では上司が決めてます。
会社が決めてます。でもアチューメントて
という会社は自分の働き方が自分の
ポジションも自分の収入もやりがい
働き買いも自分が決めてますっていう会社
なのでだから頑張ってくれてると思うんだ
よ。それでもね、まあ時代と共に今本当に
このリモートで働くことが当たり前になる
時代もっともっと工夫をしてやっぱり時代
の流れに即したやっぱりこう働く人が求め
てるもののって5つの基本的欲求を満たす
ものなので生存愛と所属力自由楽しみ真摯
ともに健康な状態それから良好な人間関係
一切の人間関係の悩みがない状態、それ
から仕事のやりがい、本当に働き、達成感
、重要感、たくさんのありがを言って
もらえる環境、そして経済的にも精神的に
も不自由が
ない状態で楽しい人生を楽しむ。この5つ
の欲求が満たされる職場をどうしたら
作れるのか、別にその他者と比較する必要
もないと思うんですよ。ま、結婚と同じで
、そんなこと比べる必要ないわけで、会社
も同じだと思うんですよ。自社はどんな
ブランドなのかなんだよ。僕がともかく
宇宙1社員を幸せにできる会社規模じゃ
なくてそれを目指してます。目指してます
。まだそうだとは言いません。グレイト
プレストワークでね、働きある会社
グランプリ取りましたよ。150カ国で中
規模部門で100名から999名の部門で
一応グランプリなんだから誇れると思うん
だけどそんなのはでもねグレイト
プレストゥワークの評価でしょうみたいな
もんな。俺はもっと理想が高いわけ
ぶっちゃけ。つまりね、統芸が粘土を
こねるようにあらゆる環境を操作して人は
その人のほっする心のイメージを実現して
いく。僕はもっとこういう会社にしたいっ
てあるわけよ。もうね、できたら集3日も
ね、実現したいよ。ただ社員は大変だと
思うよ。集計3日になったら本当に頭いい
人間じゃないと出世できなくなるよ。
単なる体で稼ぐはボットに変わっちゃったりさ、もうは作業型材はその修でしかもらえな。でも企業ってやっぱり社会に価値をしなきゃいけないんで、価値像人材を集めれる会社にしなきゃいけないんですよ。それにはやっぱり急
3日も目指す。頭で稼ぐんでシンク&
グロリッチなので体で稼ぐんなら長時間
労働の昔のもだ昔の産業革命前はもう休み
もなしで棒持った工場長がいてこんなこと
やってね。それだから老期法が生まれてき
たわけじゃん。今会社の系のやり方も本当
に変えなきゃダめだと思うよ。時代が
変わってるんだって。その時代の変化に
適用していくこと。ま、今ね、質問受けた
方にあえて言うと、ま、正直その会社が
社員を大切にしている会社ならそんな
気持ちにはならないかもしれないけど、
まず自分がともかく実でちゃんと
パフォーマンスを出してるかどうかを見て
で、自分の周りの友人にも聞いて、うちの
会社は客観的に見てどういう会社だと思
うって聞いて、それから過去現在未来の中
でその会社がどういう戦略を持って成長し
てるのかどうか伸びない会社なのかそれ
から業から見てもこれからの時代どうなの
かいろんなこと考えそして自分の適正と
照らし合わせながら本来は自分が
ものすごくパフォーマンス低い雇って
いただいてると逆にね置いていただいて
ありがとうっていう存在なのに不満も思っ
てるかもしれないしわかんないよ。それは
よく
周知というか周りの人の意見も聞きながら
判断をしてもしダメな会社ならやめた方が
いいよ。いや本当そんなとこ何年い
たってみ将来ないもん。そう思わない。
申し訳ないけど。その社長さんすいません
ね。いや実際本音だよ。でもダメな会社は
ダメなんだよ。で、何がダメかって社長が
ダメなんだから。いや、本当愛がないと
いい系にはならないんです。愛なんです
。社員を幸せにしたいと心から思っ
てまだ不完全だけどごめんねと。だから
謝る心を持ちながら経するんですよ。
俺はそうやって38年頑張ってきたよ。
もっといい会社にする。まあ、なんか
うちってさ、僕のそんなね、ま、無学歴
で用だった僕が精一杯前向きに一生懸命
生きているそういうなんだろう、未熟だっ
たけどいい経営者になりたいなっていう
気持ちはすごくありました。今もある。
うん。まだまだある。40期にはこういう
会社にしたいっていう理想に向かって
頑張ってる
からだ。周りの評価じゃないんだよな。だ
からそういう経営者と一緒に働いてるなら
自分自身感謝して頑張ればいいしそうで
ないとし
たらなんだろう転職するのも1つかもしれ
ないし分からないそれはうんだから
軽ハずみなこと言えないんだよその会社
わかんない
[音楽]
からよく考えて目を見開いて事実を見て
判断するというのがポイントじゃないかな
。ちょっと長くなったけどそんな感じいい
なと思ったら是非ね、え、高評価よろしく
。そして、え、チャンネル登録もして
ください。コメント欄にも是非ね、
コメントください。また次回の
YouTubeでおめにましょう。
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
。で、いいでもまだそんなに利益は出て
ないと報いたくても報いないんだよ。いつ
もそういう38年前創業した時代から見
たらそういう時代があったんだよ。
マンションオフィスでさ、もう高い報酬
払いたくても払えなかった。大体中途採用
でうちに入ってくるのにみんな30万の8
24万円からスタートな。入ってこない人
もいっぱいいた。でもその中で僕は出せる
範囲で精一杯頑張った。ま、はっきり言っ
て最初は精神的なものの方が8割で経済的
なものは2割ぐらいからスタートしてんだ
よ。極端に言うと。で、この精神的なもの
のって僕がトップセル、トップ
マネージャー、トップコンサルタントとし
てのノー波を持ってるから僕のそばで働
くっていうことは能力開発好きな人間、
また将来独立したいという人間にとっては
吸収できるわけだよな。つまり僕のそばで
働くことはお金には変えられないものが得
られると思って集まってきてくれた。でも
やっぱりさ、そういう人間は独立してくよ
ね。当然のことだからだ。それで
入れ替わり立ち変わりし
ながら一生懸命頑張ってそして1987年
創業あの会社設立をして2006年
2004年から始めたその新卒採用で
2005年から入り出して2006年から
3331税引利益の3割は社員還元3割は
内部流法3割が配当1割や社会加還元と
いうことを考えてそれを実行してきた。で
も最初は売上小さいじゃん。利益も小さい
じゃん。ま、社員もそれそのところは
少ないから、まあ1人の分配っていうのは
ね、それなりにはあったけれども、つまり
それは退職金として受け取るよりもね、
年光除列型就寝雇用はもう時代じゃないと
。だから今働いてる時に実績実力主義で
若くても高い報酬欲しいとよしじゃあそう
しようっていうことで前倒しでじゃ出して
あげようという風にしたわけだよ
[音楽]
決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容そのものに惚れ込ん
でるかどうかなです。